hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge it is time once again to test
our hilarious Constitution against this
ensemble of hand-picked funny videos
from all across the internet can you
survive the challenge but there's only
one way to find out now
oh and any of my fans in New Zealand or
Australia that want to see me in person
please go to tour dot markiplier calm or
click the link in the description below
to see if we're gonna be coming to a
city near you
my let's do this I don't like this
already I loved her for ages
nope cannot do two in peace oh I see
what's up there oh don't you
[ __ ] barking me I'm taking a
[ __ ] not funny
[Music]
what am i watching
[Music]
what in the fresh hell is this and what
in the goddamn what was that Pierson
decides to mmm try a maneuver called a
side slip practically unheard of on
commercial airliners but sometimes used
by glider pilots Pierson has never in
only performed a song don't do this
but he's attempting one now not allowing
767 Wow
oh stop it good God
good hmm not a laughs not a laugh isn't
that funny that's not funny that's not
funny that's not funny I love dogs no no
stop what are you doing all right then
something happened that Hugh says has
never happened to him in all his years
of climbing now one of Hugh's legs fell
off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've never seen or heard anyone try so
desperately to become a Disney Princess
and be
able to communicate with animals at that
one moment never seen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no I'm gonna get
me with that [ __ ] yeah more that's made
of [ __ ] Burdick leathers and leather
seats
[Music]
[ __ ] who says she works
[Music]
mother lives she's dead and I killed her
in the car what the [ __ ] did I just
watch what the [ __ ] I haven't got a
goddamn clue
I don't like those in the water
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they're so good letsa let's check the
patch notes for the sims 3 the Grim
Reaper will no longer be prevented from
reaping souls due to pay and affiliation
fixed a tuning issues so that Sims now
it is no longer possible to try for
babies with child with no longer appears
Sims who are on fire will no longer be
forced to attend baby Sims will no
longer become so no longer a secret wish
to skinny-dip with mummies I'm here can
hit a building which case everyone will
run out before the collision those who
do not exit the building will die Sims
automatically leave if a meteor is
approaching unless it is a school just a
lot of smiling I was laughing I swear I
was not laughing you want to hear a
station for porn detected porno Rito hot
chick amateur girl
no I [ __ ] anal dildo ringtone lets us
stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there wasn't laughing I was expecting a
poot all right fine
I know I know I've been like chuckling
through pretty much every single video
but I was trying really hard and I
didn't break fully until right there but
anyway this has been the try not to
laugh challenge did you manage to make
it through okay if you did and be honest
let me know down in the comments below
and if you have other funny videos that
you want me to react to let me know down
there as well and if you want to see
more check out the try not to laugh
challenge a playlist I'll link it in the
description and thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video